um
hi folks thank you all for joining me um
i'm a grad student here in cms
i'm a researcher let's say it's an
initiative um my thesis is called uh
trust machines cryptic cryptocurrencies
blockchains and humans and cultures of
mistrust
so um since
it appears twice let me uh start by
introducing three key points about trust
all right so trust according to stima is
a capacity to forecast future actions so
it is essentially the main condition to
exist in society with strangers we need
to have some capacity to know that
things will go a certain way
second guidance another sociologist adds
that trust is not just reliability it is
very much faith and not only faith but
it's a blind faith so for guidance we
can trust in two ways uh when we trust
our friends or family or when we trust
abstract principles um to be true so for
example when we're traveling by plane we
don't really know we don't really need
to know how a plane works we just trust
it's gonna work
um and guidance as a third thing that
modern institutions rely on people's
trust in abstract systems and a good
example of this is for example the
finance system right uh so for example
when we are exchanging money we don't
really need to understand the whole
dynamics of what goes through a credit
card transaction we just trust that
money is going to be honored
so
what brings me to public institutions
all right uh which play a try a role in
their society as trust mediators they
brokers they broke her trust between
strangers
so according to fukuyama mothers
institutions emerging societies with
historically low interpersonal trust so
another way they facilitate interactions
between people who would normally not
trust each other
and they do this through contracts or
laws and policies
but modern states are not just a
functional aspect of these institutions
benedict anderson says that the national
states are rooted in something called
imagine communities uh so media
technologies like books maps senses they
uh they help
just diffuse this idea that we all share
some common identity that we're part of
something bigger
and
so imagine communities uh go from this
idea of uh they expand trust from our
close friendships to something bigger to
a wider polity and robert putnam talks
about two accounts of trust one is based
on our personal strong frequent
relationships thick trust and then trust
which refers to the trust we have uh
with
people with some shared social networks
or expectations of reciprocity so
imagine communities enable this thin
trust
but
what happens when people mistrust
these institutions
um so ethan zuckerman argues that when
some people confront oppressive systems
they can become instructionists who try
to overthrow and upheave existing
systems and one of these levers for
change is code uh network technologies
are interesting because they can indeed
transfer attributions that were before
monopolies of the state to market
systems so for example before social
media platforms like facebook censorship
was something that more or less
generally the state only did now with
these platforms is attribution that is
shared to the market
and in cold lawrence classic argues that
the internet is governed by something
called merchant sovereignty so profit
who prioritize profit making over public
good and provide no accountability to
the public he says that a relationship
to them to them is the same that we have
to mcdonald's um
so my interest is in these technological
systems as market sovereignties these
are trust machines technological systems
that mediate trusts and that operate
through market principles
so specifically these are my research
questions first how is technological
trust mediator addressing a perceived
mistrust in public institutions what are
the individual and collective practices
involved in this new mediation what is
the role of affects and emotion and how
are public institutions transforming in
response to these emerging imaginaries
and i explored this question by focusing
a specific case study which is the use
of cryptocurrencies in argentina and let
me show you
why in the first before that i'm going
to say let's go
so
this thesis focuses on a specific
long-dated competence of the state
which is governing money so as most uh
folks know here uh james carey points at
two versions of communications as
transmission and communication as ritual
so scholars of media studies have
studied money as most of these things
so first in the poor man's credit card
marshall mcluhan says that money talks
because money is a metaphor a transfer a
bridge as a vast social metaphor a
bridge or translator money like writing
speeds up the exchange and tightens the
bonds of interdependence in any
community and the new money lana's worth
says that money technologies produce
transactional communities networks of
relations united by a common sense of
identity geography and values and i'm
happy to talk more about this review
blood review in the q a if folks have
any questions about how media studies
addresses money
now let's move on to uh to the
technology that we're looking at which
is cryptocurrencies
and these are digital currencies that
exist in blockchains which are
decentralized records that are
compulsive blocks that are tied together
through cryptography and this might not
be super clear and i'm happy to answer
more technical questions but what we
need to know is that it works like
decentralized digital money and the
blockchain was invented in 2008 by a
mysterious figure called sadoshi
nakamoto who we don't know who that is
and to support bitcoin which is a
cryptocurrency and nagamoto published
bitcoin uh in the white paper of bitcoin
a whale made english about crypto
cryptography
as a new technology uh that enables a
peer-to-peer version of electronic cash
that will that would allow direct
payments without going through a
financial institution
another the bitcoin the most utilized
blockchain is ethereum blockchain
ethereum is an open source blockchain
created in 2013
relies on cryptocurrency called ether
unassuming innovation that it supports
smart contracts which are code that is
executed automatically in this
blockchain and it supports tokens which
are other cryptocurrencies in the
ethereum blockchain
and now why am i focused in argentina
for many reasons for one argentina has
gone through a series of political
economic crisis i'm just gonna say that
because i could just spend the entire
presentation on that and secondly after
an inflationary crisis crisis in 2001
argentina has had increasing inflation
um then in june 2021 argentina ranked uh
10th in each analysis global
cryptocurrency adoption index which
means that argentina's are adopting
crypto at an additional rate
and in edelman's 2022 trust barometer
our survey of 37 countries argentina
ranked last in two categories trust in
government and trust in the central bank
and also in argentina we can see the
existence of um of informal economic
networks like barter networks understand
currency exchanges when people can
bypass the government's restrictions on
purchasing foreign currency
so my focusing in understanding
cryptocurrencies in argentina allows me
to understand how a technological trust
mediator cryptocurrencies is understood
alongside problems in public
institutions
so obama methods i conducted in-depth
interviews with 15 cryptocurrency users
enthusiasts and blockchain technology
developers in argentina
i recruited them through something that
i call extended snowball sampling which
is
getting in touch with people that my
informants pension but also seeing who
they share twitter spaces or other
virtual communities with i use digital
ethnography methods to understand how
users engage in virtual communities and
lastly i use the walkthrough method to
explore the artifacts that users engage
with and this method as described by
live burgers and dugway aims to
establish a software applications
environment of expected use which is how
an app provider expects it will be
received generate profit or other forms
of benefit
on regular user activity
so i will now present the chapters in my
thesis and some of the findings
so my first chapter is called the legacy
systems and i'm going to spend a bit
more time on this one because it's
especially important so the scholars of
media know that adoption of media
technologies is tied to the visions of
its users so social political context is
important but they only tell part of the
picture it also matters how technology
is framed as a solution to a problem
um for scholars of media studies this
might ring a bell which is winston's
idea of supervising social necessities
by looking at the role of ideology too
so in this chapter a look at how
blockchains and cryptocurrencies are
framed as updates for outdated legacy
systems traditional institutions are com
are are seen as outdated artifacts that
this technology has come to
revolutionize as louisa informant told
me crypto libra liberates individuals
from a lot of obstacles set by
institutions that don't really work for
them
so three public institutions are
addressed here the national state
traditional finance and public identity
so
um first national states are seen as
mistrusted so my informants often frame
crypto as bypassing national borders and
offering a level field for people
worldwide its revolutionary potential
wasn't pursued through the re-centering
of the capacity of individuals but it's
not just about individualism the playing
field visions applies also to social
barriers and nicolas a 27 year old
cryptocurrency trader explained to me
the adoption of the technologies relies
on the solidarity of the argent and
cryptic community
crypto for me is literal liberty and the
capacity to engage with people who
traditionally will not be at your level
in the crypto world you can easily talk
to someone who is 50 or 500 bitcoins
without this person talking down on you
you can have a conversation in the same
wavelength
another institution that uh that was
opposed was traditional finance another
informant said that crypto comes to
decentralize and change the way that
institutions use money so i'm not in
favor of the idea that you give money to
the bank and the bank moves around the
money and then they charge you and this
software relates to how the government
uses money which is related to to
inflation they say and lastly public
identity is a contested idea they
negotiate the idea of their the
anonymity granted by the centralized
networks but also the idea of publicness
needed in the sociality of
the technology engaging with something i
call fluid anonymity
and what's interesting here is that
argentine entrepreneurs and developers
are imagining new institutions using
blockchain technologies an example of
this is essential on a project developed
that situates a virtual
3d world in the blockchain and works
through by smart contracts making its
government incorruptable and fully
transparent
another project we're mentioning is
proof of humanity which is a
which is a registry of individuals on
the blockchain where users can validate
their identity as humans and
automatically receive money these are
profit making enterprises of course as
each project becomes more popular their
tokens become more pricey and the office
of assets of the original creators
increase in value but they can also be
seen as experiments in world may
experiment in world building of
understanding what artifacts are
necessary to replace the obsolete ones
that sustain the national state as such
so in the second chapter i critically
engage with the idea of trustlessness in
the blockchain
um that is commonly presented as a
tourism in literature the idea of
trustlessness presents an essential
binary between the everyday world and
the blockchain decentralized trustless
blockchain
um and this chapter aimed to deconstruct
this opposition so by focusing on the
different gateways to acquiring
cryptocurrencies by argentine users and
to highlight the role of off-chain
transactions in determinants once
engagement with cryptocurrencies so
analyze a serial has a series of
technologies and arrangements or human
and non-human actors uh like custodial
or non-custodial wallets or local
exchanges and clandestine brokers
peer-to-peer marketplaces i find that
how a user engages with cryptocurrency
is dependent on choices that are
dependent on the political social ties
existing existence in the off-chain
world
for example known custodial wallets were
artifacts for managing cryptocurrencies
where users have access to the private
and public keys which makes it very
private but also very risky the users of
this shared
the user of this technology shared with
me a vision of complete mistrust in the
government but custodial wallets wells
that rely on businesses and therefore uh
need users to authenticate their
identity and this identity is shared
with the government uh we're understood
as a bridge between the off-chain
government relations on the affordances
of the blockchain they were also
associated with the reliance on their
reliance on legal safeguards
since they are legal entities another
interesting finding was that when so
when social media platforms like
facebook where you use like a
marketplace for cryptocurrencies the
affordances of facebook to build trust
that the requirements use real names
were repurposed by the users
the third chapter focuses on how
communitarianism is performed in the
community and centers the role of affect
and emotion in community building wagmi
is a common phrase among ethereum
enthusiasts that means we're all going
to make it it does not represent all the
crypto community but it's a it's a good
representation not the idea of
solidarity and communitarianism in
argentina's crypto community
and community building is seen as an
important task for crypto enthusiasts um
natalia an informant described the
community as a place for consultation
she believes there are three pillars in
a community bringing new people into the
community making the community grow and
making sure that making it so the
communities contribute to that community
cryptocurrency users employ different
social media platforms and chat
applications to fulfill different
communicative needs for example twitter
is useful to connect with like-minded
enthusiasts
but the information there is an
expectation of authoritativeness discord
and telegram are useful as spaces for
specific interests or affinities and to
share information more casually
and being seemingly public they can
allow newcomers to cryptocurrencies to
ask questions and whatsapp groups are
seen as more intimate and allow for
information to be shared less
authoritatively allowing you users to
share riskier products and here's an
interesting thing
so these communities uh this community
spaces also play a role in managing
emotions collectively like foot which is
fear uncertainty and doubt and full mo
the fear of missing out when a new
product appears and the volatility of
the cryptocurrencies is emotionally
taxing so virtual communities access
enthusiast report systems as an
informant told me i mean who in your
family can understand what you go
through in this chaos that goes so fast
and lastly different communities engage
in different gatekeeping strategies to
authorize and validate information so
for example a community uh for women in
crypto uh the community the moderation
of community for women in crypto demand
links to be validated beforehand with
them so um before they had posted in the
group and they didn't see this as
holding authority but as protecting
community members from misinformation
and granting them tools to make
decisions by themselves
and lastly the last chapter in my thesis
is about future making and this is a big
thing about my thesis
this emerging imaginary is affecting how
institutions understand themselves so in
this final chapter asks how are public
institutions uh transforming in response
to these emerging imaginaries
and in this chapter i perform a close
reading of a white paper recently
published by the city of buenos aires
secretary of innovation and digital
transformation created in collaboration
with developers on the blockchain
community and the paper is about
identity protocols based in the
blockchain and it echoes many of the
values and visions i identified in this
first chapter a vision of the
centralization through censoring of
individuals and granting users power
over their value this is in line with
the vision of what eric gordon and i
call transparent institutions guided by
the erasure of discretion and automatic
enforcement through smart contracts the
erasure of this question is something
that's been at the core of beverage
vision of the bureaucratic state but
other social theories like lipsky or
sacca
argue that the discretion is actually
essential to public service prohibition
so in a way the blockchain promises a
reversal of guidance understanding of
trust in modern institutions so as a
reminder uh guidance said that when we
trust modern institutions we trust in
abstract systems things that we don't
really know or cannot really think about
but the blockchain but blockchain users
do not primarily place trust in abstract
systems they do so in the material
system of the blockchain itself so
blockchain presents an opportunity for
public institutions to provide effective
functions without the need for the
institution to be trusted itself outside
those functions
so this is a new vision of trust that is
supportive of these new technologies
so all right thank you for listening and
i hope this presentation has provided
you with uh with a window and so until
the imaginaries behind this technology
with behind what this technology means
for a collective lies like
and
thank you and i would like to especially
thank my advisors eric gordon and t.l
taylor who have been fantastic mentors
my cohort who has been an ideal
community to think with folks at the
civic design initiative the latin
american media studies reading group and
my friends and family in boston and
board of scientists who have been
incredible support for this thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much
i don't know if you ended up like going
there and exploring
that but for me that was
establishment where you can trade
different currencies and buy crypto
um and if i got there i have not gone
there but um luckily there
is a topic that's been explored in their
literature not about crypto but uh so oh
wait context about argentina you cannot
buy us dollars legally because the
government forbids that to keep
inflation low and prices lower but so so
what you actually when you want to buy
dollars to save against inflation you
have to go to cuevas which are kind of
climate design establishments which are
actually pretty front-facing because the
government tolerates them a lot so um so
the situation around cuevas is that
cuevas also trading crypto all right so
they can either sell you uh currencies
like uh ether or bitcoin but they can
also sell you something called stable
coins which are um cryptos that are tied
to one dollar so you know always know
that your token is also always going to
be one dollar
and there are two things here uh when
you
when you engage with aguero you're
usually using your non custodial wallet
which uh it's a very it's a risky thing
because if imagine you have some sort of
problem with acuela um then you have no
one to you know you have no recourse you
have you cannot tell the government hey
this person sold for me so for example
an informant told me that
someone had gone through an interaction
with uh where they actually sent them
their wallet to exchange to send them
their crypto to but the
uh administrator actually swiped and got
their private wallet which means they
took power over the entire wall
and
and this informant told me well then you
know since the blockchain is pretty
transparent you can actually trace
transactions very easily uh people you
know trace back to where this uh where
the transactions were taken and then
really tarnished the reputation of the
cueva right but the thing is that the
the reputation of the cueva that only
gets known in a very small circle so
that actually
sheds light on how social capital uh
off-chain social capital from you know
the real world affects our engagement
with the with the blockchain right so
that's interesting and also something
very interesting is that for uh so my
informants saw me abuelas are good for
small amounts but when you want to have
bigger amounts you need arbolito and
volito is one that it's like a smaller
scale cueva which uh pretty much goes to
your house and you go to their house or
to somewhere more private and that
person like it's a
uh reliable transaction for big amounts
so um you need to be introduced to those
people they're not people you can find
on the street like with us so
that also should slide how social
capital uh uh works there so you know
when you're trusting diabolito you're
actually trusting the person who put you
in touch with the volito and that volito
knows that you cannot like you know
cannot play tricks because you'll be
sacrificing your relationship with that
thank you
i just watched this documentary
around crypto but actually in practice
there's not much yeah or at least there
are points where there is
so tl asks about the rhetoric of
transparency and how that is contrasted
to reality where things might be much
more opaque and power relations might be
especially salient and there are there
is a great paper by that about gilibidan
which actually should slide on how for
example bitcoin has the idea of being
decentralized for example but they're
actually a bunch of factors have a lot
more power like miners or whales which
are people who own a lot of crypto and
they can also have a lot of market power
on things
um but regarding the idea of
transparency i think you know um
i think you care a lot about the
discourse of transparency
and how is that that's at this corset
thing and to see how institutions
respond to that and whether they do it
in a meaningful way or not and i think a
lot of work has done actually you know
like uh uncovering the real empower
relations in the blockchain and say well
this idea of of of democraticness or
communitarism or horizontality is
problematic and i think that's
interesting but it's not exactly what i
was trying to do in my thesis
i was to some extent taking a discourse
of my information for granted and
respecting them uh what they had to say
and and kind of exploring these ideas
and then see how this discord is this
course is read by institutions and
replicated that's what i do in my last
chapter so i i think that what's
valuable um it's not necessarily whether
things are are materially true or not
because in in reality people think or
believe that some one thing is true that
is valuable and that is a zeitgeist that
defines the media moment right the
ideology essentially uh which is why i
think my thesis pays a lot of attention
to two categories which are ideology and
imaginaries so imaginaries is this
category that uh sheila jason of
invented over here at harvard uh over
there harvard um and it's the idea that
people have this visions of technology
in their heads right and that this
visions are shared collectively and then
they become stabilized and crystallized
in institutions right when the
government or a public student says all
right we're gonna go forward this
direction right and i'm interested in
seeing that jump
so
i think there's a lot of work on the
material actuality on the contrast
between decentralization and
decentralized and centralization the
power relations but
i think other people do much better than
me
thank you
yeah so actually so trustee asked me
about how media studies uh addresses
money so
actually something interesting about
media is that the like the origins of
the word medium are tied to money right
medium of exchange um so
it's it's a it's a very long competency
also of media but also social sciences
right not only economics which are you
know the signs of money but also the
idea that for example guidance when he
talks about trust and abstract systems
he talks about exchange system money as
an abstract system right uh but now
there have been uh
two big books recently that addressed
this which are lana swartz
uh see you as a person uh who um who
talks about new money and the
transactional communities and media
technologies and the
the communitarian part and the cultural
aspect of this um i'm finn burton who
talks about digital cash and these two
books i think are are giving a twist on
on money but i think it's really
interesting and that is i think um
trace it's it actually shuts light in a
on a ship we're seeing where all of our
apps especially the ones done by mera
are now becoming apps to send us money
all right so for example what's up in
brazil is piloting um how sending
payments through to whatsapp um um i
know wechat offers uh a chat uh money
transaction and you know venmo as long
as parts talks about it in the book it's
essentially social media so it's the new
attention the socks cards have me as the
media cities are paying attention to
money um and i think that's a very
exciting direction
yes
could you say more about
um
how
your informants negotiate
the
so it sounds like
they have this trust in the thing that's
called a material thing called a watch
strategy
that i've heard
in the united states is like come on
people this is not trustless you're just
trusting different things in fact
sometimes you're just like trusting the
government through another kind of thing
you know
your last statement it made me feel like
the response was just saying like
blockchain is trustless you know like
just sort of like not back here and all
[Music]
so the question was about um well the
idea of trustlessness
should be maybe more complicated because
when you're engaging with
cryptocurrencies you trust for example
wallets or companies or these are
different ways of mediating with the
government and i think that's a very
interesting point and something i do
challenge in my thesis so there's this
idea of trustlessness which is a
an idea that was crystallized in
academic literature by maya philippe um
also harvard um and
what this idea of trust is i i i into
deconstructed a little bit because one
thing is when it's echoed by our
informants and i think that in that in
that case it's it's good to pull it out
as this corset thing but when we
replicate it on the literature it
becomes a bit more shaky right because i
think we should address it more
critically so what i do in chapter in
chapter two of my thesis is i
deconstruct the death process right um
but i i do see that there are some some
ways of bypassing the government so for
example you have two
two wallets all right two uh like
ways of ones
one are non-custodial wallets where you
actually own your public and private key
which are the things that in the
blockchain give you a 30 over handling
transactions which is the power of your
money
and then there's um there's custodial
exchanges because exchanges are
companies right uh you don't have power
over your public over your private keys
uh you can only see your private public
key and your private key is owned by the
government so when you're trying to buy
crypto you're buying crypto against the
company right so this companies are
registered with the government um they
you know if if your money goes missing
you can you know go to the government
hey you these guys took my money um
but then again it requires these
companies to tell the government who you
are it requires you go to something
called kyc which is a know your customer
uh process so um
whereas non-custodial wallets you can
actually go to acueva or any clandestine
exchange and actually have a transaction
without the government knowing what goes
in the middle so
i think trusting the government there i
think there is something interesting
about the government being bypassed as
an institution in something that the
government had power of over which is
money right either the argentine
government or the u.s government with
the u.s dollars but essentially a
competence of the government um
regardless the idea of mediations of
trust i agree that the idea of
trustlessness is not very useful as it
is a discourse of construct right um but
i do think that it's interesting to look
at the mediations of trust and see what
networks of trust emerge in that way
right so for example when i'm trusting a
cursorial wallet i am to some extent
trusting the government i am some
exchange trusting the the company that
made the custodial one and when i'm not
trusting when i'm using a non-custodial
word i'm trusting the clan design person
who is doing a peer-to-peer transaction
or i'm trusting the social media network
through which i found the other person
like facebook or or binance's peer to
peer network
thank you
thank you so much all right thank you